ام مازن كانت هذه التصريحات لافته لقائد
مجموعه فاجنر والتي تهم من خلالها رئيس
هيئه الاركان وايضا وزير الدفاع بالخيانه
والسبب بحسب عدم تسليم معدات لقواته وايضا
عدم تسهيل تنقل هذه القوات كيف
تتعامل ربما
الرئاسه الروسيه والاوسط العسكريه مع هذه
التصريحات
كيف يتعلق بالرئاسه الروسيه من السعر
القول ان طرف في هذا الخلاف وان كان يعني
هناك توقعات وتتكه هناك مختلفه حول دور
الكريملين في ذلك ولكن لا شك ان الاوساط
العسكريه تتعامل مع مجموعه فاجنر بشكل
يختلف تماما عما كان يتوقعه بريجوجل
مجموعه فاغنر توسع دورها ونفوذها خلال
الخليفه الماضي في العمليات العسكريه
اعتمدت بالدرجه الاولى على تجنيد المساجين
قرار ايقاف تجنيد المساجين للقتال في
ميليشيات فاجنر اعتبره عمليا ضربه في مقتل
ميليشياتي باعتبار انه فقد اكثر من نصف
المقاتلين في اوكرانيا وبالتالي ويقلص من
قدراته على توسيع
نفوذه في المناطق التي تدور فيها المعارك
وايضا يضعف قدراته على تنفيذ المهام التي
او الملقاه على عاتقه تحدث عن ذلك علنا
واعتبر ان سبب ذلك والبيروقراطيه العسكريه
التي لا تهتم باسراع بانهاء العمليه
العسكريه هذا كانت اول ضربه والضربه
الثانيه هي الامدادات التي تتحدث عنها
مؤخرا يبدو ان هناك ربما تباين او ربما
حتى خلاف بين القيادات العسكريه في مساله
التحرك وتوسيع نفوذ منشيه في المناطق لك
مازن عباس مراسلنا من موسكو شكرا